us maybe it's a terrific kid I don't  know how I bring that school without her  well yeah I mother did a wonderful job  raising her I'll forget every suit you  Mormon does she know that you're getting  older you don't to be reminded reminded  of what really yeah you're gonna make me  say it come on say it wrong what that is  so wrong I'm walking away from you I  need my coat I'm sorry baby baby can I  buy a new coat you owe three years worth  of taxes Oh sir fiscal years sweetheart  is different  hello you want to tell me what's going  on I just put my 45 year old daughter in  rehab for the eighth time just keep  going  [Music]  Who am I supposed to do with her I guess  just love her you're useless  you